Hello and welcome to our webcast,
MBA Student Insights:
International Students at the GSB.
My name is Tong Zhang, and I'm a first
year MBA student here at the GSB.
I'm joined by my classmate Artem and
Michael, also known by Hobbsy,
will be talking about the student
experience here at the GSB, and
we'll answer as many of
your questions as we can.
So send in a question to us about
what it's like to be a student.
Just click the chat button at the top
of your screen, enter the question, and
click send to all panelists.
Please be aware that we won't be able
to talk about admission process,
applications, financial aid,
or the visa process today.
You can consult the website or
contact the MBA Admissions office for
that information.
So let's begin with introductions.
Where we are from, what we were each
doing before coming to the GSB, and
the what are our goals after graduation.
I'll start.
So I grew up in China.
I came to the states 6 years
ago to study journalism.
Before the GSB,
I was a tech NMA reporter in New York.
After the GSB I plan to move into tech and
help build tech enabled platforms to
help distribution of media content.
How about you?
>> Perfect, thank you Tong for
the introduction.
So my name is Artem I'm
from Russia originally.
Most of my life I lived in Moscow.
And the career wise before GSB.
I was mainly just being company, so
I spent more than four years management
consulting across Europe and
also South Africa office.
And regarding the post GSB goals, I am
still considering my different options.
>> Hobbsy?
>> Yeah, so thank you very much for
your introduction.
I am from New Zealand originally
I was a professional rugby player
before coming to GSB.
Five of those years in New Zealand and
then the last three in Japan.
With regard to my post graduation goals,
I am currently exploring a career
in the real estate industry, which I'll
be doing an internship over the summer.
And hopefully sort of
proceeding from there.
>> Nice.
All right, so we'll start with some
questions submitted by the audience.
So the first question will be,
did you guys consider schools out
of the US when you were applying?
What was your consideration between
US schools and non US schools, and
why did you choose Stanford?
>> Yeah, I'm happy to start from this one.
So, as they said, right,
most of my life I spent in Europe, and
obviously I considered
European schools as well.
The way my decision process went, so
basically since I spent all of the time
in Europe, just the idea of spending some
time in America was more exciting to me
because it was new geographically for me.
And also, when I saw thought about the
value of MB, I saw what kind of doors, and
means of opportunity that
can be opened for me.
And I had a perception that and American
MBA, it opens some doors in America,
but also in Europe and Asia,
it's kind of like global degree,
whereas European and Asian schools, they
are more kind of like one region focused.
So from that kind of
flexibility perspective,
American MBA made sense to me.
>> Cool.
>> Yeah, no I also explored sort
of MBA programs outside the US,
mainly in the UK focused on Cambridge and
Oxford.
I think one of the biggest
things Ivan touched on
a few of them are the global reach.
It was a big one for me.
But also the fact I really like the two
year program versus the one year, so
the 12 month program.
Reason for that coming from
the non-traditional background,
I like the idea of being able to, it's
been my first year exploring industries,
having some internship to explore that to
see if that is what I really want to do.
And having a second year if I could
change that to something else.
For further, I continue down that track.
>> That's okay.
So how about why Stanford?
>> Yes.
>> I couldn't talk about my experience.
So I've been working in
the US before GSB so
my choice was supposed mostly
focusing on US schools.
And I know I want to move into tag and
I feel Standford the proximity to
Silicon Valley will be a great place,
and also I'm really
drawn to the spirit of personal reflection
and committee building here at GSB.
So that's what's one of my inspirations.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah, so for me,
it's quite an easy question, and
I think the answer going to be very
similar to what Tong just said, so.
First of all,
it's definitely about Silicon Valley,
to a large extent,
like a very exciting place to live in,
considering how many cool
things are happening around.
And also, I was very fortunate to meet
many people from the GSB community,
even before applying to the school.
And I just,
I felt I clicked with those people and
I felt I shared all the values with them.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which is the idea of spending of two
years in the community of disabled
people was very attractive to me.
>> Yeah, thank you.
Many of the same points feel that
adds will be, one, the class size.
I really like the fact that it was
a size of 400 a class, that's 800,
900 in some of the top schools in
the US I thought that intimacy,
getting to know classmates,
was a big thing for me.
Second, location, in California.
I mean, and the campus,
the amazing campus we have.
You take one walk around here,
it's pretty hard to sort of turn away and
say you'd like to go somewhere else.
And then thirdly,
it was just the caliber of students
that I was going to be alongside.
So for me,
it was from a non traditional background,
wanting to explore different industries.
So that I would sort of,
the tidal waves or
boats being around people
really high caliber.
>> Exactly.
Yeah, I see with the other question.
So, how has been the transition
to the ESL of education been?
Is it hard for you,
adjusting from what you were used to?
>> Mm hm.
I can start here, so
I actually studied abroad in the US, for
one semester back in 2011.
So I'd had some exposure to it previously,
but
honestly for me,
it wasn't that big of a transition.
I've done higher education in New Zealand
and Australia previously as well, and
it was very similar teaching styles.
Very similar curriculum.
So it wasn't a huge transition for me.
>> I would say for
me it was like difficult as well.
So before, there was an academic
experience, I started Elise.
Being multi-defined over there.
And I would say that over all
the experience is quite similar.
The only thing that surprised
me quite a lot is that,
I would say like the intensity
of the education.
At GSB it stands that if I'd ever sit,
for example,
we have one course that runs for all the
whole year and then we have an exam then.
Here we have three quarters.
Here a long academic year and within
each quarter you have the final exam.
You have the mid term and
you have a lot of group assignments.
So like the intensity of
the overall process is
something that surprised me quite a lot,
but
I assume that's pretty much from where the
experience and the knowledge comes from.
>> Yeah I would just add one point,
I feel the class participation or
case based discussion is find something
I feel struggled a bit to adjust.
Because coming from Asian culture from
China you were supposed to sit there and
just find some questions when
your teacher asks you to.
But that way I feel I need to push myself
a little bit to like raise my hand and
jump in.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool.
So how about talk about how
welcoming do you feel about the GSB
community to internationals?
>> I'm happy to start on this one.
I think, first of all, like 40% of people
at GSB are from international background,
which makes GSB by definition kind of
welcoming to the international community,
because it's an international community.
I also would say that GSB,
has quite a lot of tools
to involve people and to make them
part of the broader community.
By tools, what do I mean by tools.
First of all sections,
the fact that we start for
the first quarter and
we are starting the section,
70 people who we got to know quite well
over the first two months of the program.
And then you have a squad which
becomes your inner family,
seven people who you know really,
really well.
Also, you have cooperativity.
Most of the people live on campus so
you bond with many people and
build smaller communities within
the residential area you live in.
So there are quite a few tools that
incorporate you into the broader
community.
>> Yeah, echoing a lot of
those points again, I think,
I live on campus directly across
the street from where we take classes.
I think I'm sort of one of a couple
of international students in my wing.
So there's that forced
interaction with US students,
with other international students which
makes it such a welcoming community.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And I'd also say the support staff we
have in the MBA Office have been amazing
helping us if we wanted to talk to
an immigration lawyer,
putting on different sort of BBLs and
different events that if we have any
questions that need to be answered.
And then again,
in the greater Stanford community,
having been to international
center's been a great resource.
So yeah, felt very well with that.
>> Yeah, that's great.
Yeah, you guys both mentioned
about the social aspect.
But how about the classroom setting?
How do you think the academic experience
has been incorporated into international
experience into or integrated?
>> Mm-hm.
>> [CROSSTALK] Yeah, so I mean, I'm in a
class right now, strategy beyond markets.
It's essentially focused on
everything international.
We have one or two classes on the US
healthcare system but besides that,
it's all around nternational issues.
We did a case last week on Splash
mobile networks with payment system.
>> Yeah.
>> In Ghana.
I feel that it has been
incorporated in different classes.
They're always trying to incorporate
at least a few international cases into
the classwork.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And just a couple of words from my
experience.
My experience, most of the classes I'm
taking, yeah I would say they are probably
more tilted towards
the American companies' cases.
But at the same time I think most
of the cases, they teach there,
they teach quite universal lessons which
are applicable to the global issues.
So I wouldn't say that I personally
consider that to be an issue.
>> Yeah, because the knowledge
of the skills, the framework.
>> Quite universal, yeah.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah,
because we're talking about the academics,
maybe we can also touch up on your
favorite academic experience so far.
I can start off.
So I really love the group projects
a lot of the classes ask us to do.
So last quarter, I took the data and
decisions pilot class.
So we are supposed to help alumni's
company and to do a regression project.
So in the whole quarter,
I worked with four other
classmates to do a whole R-model.
For me,
coming from a journalism background,
that was a huge learning experience.
I enjoy working with people,
working with my classmates and see
a project actually helping a company grow.
So that's my favorite experience.
How about Artem, do you have any?
>> I think I enjoyed most of the classes
that are heavy on the number
of guest speakers.
In particular the two classes on the top
of my mind would be the product launch,
the advanced marketing class.
And also the money making class.
So the product launch one, we had quite
a few entrepreneurial guest speakers,
which every conversation is.
And also the money and banking class,
there are quite a few guest
speakers from the Federal Bank.
So I think that there's elements who
have access to the practitioners
from the industry, this is something
that I benefited most from.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Yeah I mean there's a couple
classes that come to mind for me.
I really enjoyed organization
behavior in the first quarter.
Franklin, and I think is one of
the greatest officials going around and
I loved how just applicable
all that material was
to daily interactions with people.
I really enjoyed sports,
business management class last quarter.
>> Yeah.
>> Again, guest speakers amazing,
GM of the Warriors, owner of
the San Francisco Giants, just amazing,
amazing guest speakers.
And I'm thinking that's one of the great
things about Stanford is that we have that
ability to bring in that kind of talent.
And then the class that I'm in right now,
real estate investment class.
We've been given 24A just north of
Milpitas, just 30 minutes south from here.
Having to put together a development plan,
being given an alumni mentor and
working through that process,
these real world applicable skills,
which I think has been really amazing.
>> Great, let's change gear a bit and
talk about student activities, so
talk about your favorite
extracurricular activities so far.
I can start off because last Friday
we just had the GSB show and
I'm part of the leadership team.
I was the stage manager.
Though a little bit background at the GSB
show is the student run original musical.
So we put together the whole script and
the whole production.
It was in the Fox Theater.
We had 1200 people coming.
It was a great production.
I feel super excited to be part of that
and just feel like be in that experience
with your classmate and
see the whole thing put together.
It's just a great rewarding experience for
me.
>> Yeah, no,
do the show would definitely be seen like
quite a success gradual from that one.
>> Thanks.
>> In my experience I would say that most
of the activities organized by the clubs
which is basically like
entreprenueral club, finance clubs.
Those activities were really, really good
and this again connects to the point
I made earlier on the guest
speakers because most of those
activities are related to the people,
the practitioners coming to the GSB.
>> Yeah
>> And
also a couple of weeks ago we made a visit
to the Slack office which was a very
quite insightful to see how their
organization works on the inside, and
also I can see how amazing
facilities we have here.
I just mean like tennis courts,
swimming pools.
>> Using all of that [LAUGH] facilities.
>> [LAUGH] Quite a few of them.
Not like all of them but
like I am doing my best.
>> Hey.
>> And I think yeah, a big one for me was
two weekends ago we had Challenge for
Charity.
>> Yeah.
Do you mind sharing with us background?
>> Yeah, a little bit of background, it's
kind of a competition between the biggest
I think six or
seven West Coast business schools.
There's a few different facets of it.
There's sort of volunteer hours,
there's fundraised money, and then there's
this event, Challenge for Charity,
which is held at Stanford every year.
Just amazing events, sports,
spelling bees, trivia competitions.
>> What sport do you play?
>> So
unfortunately they didn't have rugby, so
I tried my-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Hand at American football,
flag football, ultimate Frisbee,
and the cricket as well.
So I know cricket from back home, but
the other two are more sort of American
sports that I tried my hand at.
But also on the cultural side
having the battle of the bands,
having the dance off on Saturday night,
and
then a sort of a big event
culminating in a bit of a social.
We can interact with other business
school students from the area which is
great to build your network.
And looking at sort of career posts.
>> Yeah, cool,
I feel like you two are already
integrate into your culture pretty well.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, so a question,
the plan after GSB.
So do you plan to go
back to your own country?
And not only after graduation,
also summer plans,
making you catch up on your plans,
so what you're thinking.
>> Sure, every summer I'm doing splits,
I'm doing a global experience.
Or GMX in Europe for six weeks and
then coming back and
doing eight weeks in the US.
Equity on the real estate investing side.
Post I'd like to stay in the US,
I think it makes a lot of sense with
the amazing network that we have here.
And obviously, we get the one
year OPT on our student visa, so
I'd like to utilize that and
then make a decision from that.
>> Thank you [INAUDIBLE].
>> In my case, I'm definitely going to
go home in June, this summer.
For the second half of the summer
I plan to be in Bay area,
conducting research here.
And then after graduation to be decided.
>> Okay, cool.
So when you are looking or summer work or
you are thinking about your career plans.
What are the resources from GSB that
offer you as an international student.
How do you feel supported by
the career management system here?
>> Mm-hm, sure, I can take this one.
So they've been amazing.
The CMC, for me, has been great,
they probably saw far too much of me.
Last quarter, because without having
the corporate sort of work experience
pre-GSB I was quite nervous about getting
an internship, but they were great.
They have a wealth of knowledge,
a wealth of contacts.
Go in,
do some different activities on the board,
find out what you may be passionate
about or may be adventurous.
And they reach out and
put you in touch with CEOs of companies.
So for me, they were great,
and it was a great resource.
>> Yeah, I would jump in, because
there was an office specifically for
international students,
social organized workshop for all kinds
of work visas and CDT and how can you
stay here in the summer or the long run.
And also she will pass on opportunities
to specific international students.
So I feel, personally,
I got to took care of from
the career management centers, yeah.
>> So, also, how supportive the student
body, do you feel that it's
a competitive environment, or do you
think it's pretty cool collaborative?
How would you describe it?
>> Yeah, so I'm happy to take this one.
I think they're the quite healthy
balance on the competitiveness and
the support within the community.
Among the competitiveness I think by
design when you put in one place for
100 people will be
the average amount of 730.
It will results in some level competition.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But at the same time,
I think the way
the admission process works.
Admission committee managed to select
people who were quite nice and supportive.
So at the end of the day, it's quite
a healthy balance that can apply this year
and helps you to develop your personal and
professional skills.
But at the same time,
it supports you enough not to stress
too much about the whole process.
>> I feel JSB is known for her pretty
friendly work cooperative environment,
I feel people self selecting in
a way also too to opt into the set.
So for me, I feel really supported
because I feel here I think Huggy and
we all lived together on
campus across the street.
So people treat you as a person, as
a friend, first up like classmate second.
Where like I can put all the tasks I
feel here, I can give up really deep
relationships with all my classmate and
become a really great friend.
So that's something I feel was
different or unique here at GSB.
>> Yeah, so the next trip,
our question would be, is it common for
a student postgraduate school, for
their goals to change during
the program for the two years?
Maybe you can talk about your experience,
whether you were thinking of applying,
has anything changed?
>> Yeah, I think I've had
an interesting experience.
Obviously, I came in wanting to
explore different industries, but
I thought that I was going to go,
I had some experience in internships in
investment banking and
sort of off shore finance roles.
And I was thinking that I was going to
go into private equity and explore that.
But once I got here, talking to people,
meeting alumni,
sharing with classmates I did change.
And I sort of pivoted last quarter once
I sort of felt I had a real passion for
real estate and
found that through classes and classmates.
So I think it is very common.
It's very common for people to try out
a new industry or a new function over
summer and then realize that is
initially what they want to do.
And come back and push the reset button
and change track and [INAUDIBLE],
I think it's extremely important.
>> Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, I feel I came into the program
really wanting to go into tech,
on to be a product master.
I want to move into a pure tech company.
Also, I feel throughout talking to people,
through informational interviews,
I realized my true passion is
to journalism or publishing.
So I want to kind of
focus on my strengths,
not just trying to learn
quoting at everything.
But more work on the media product on
their strategy or publisher side so
that I can leverage my background.
So that's kind of a pivot for me.
So do you have anything to add?
>> Yeah, I've a couple of words.
So I think again like this beauty
of two years, MBA also helps a lot,
because the first year at least people
can say you really opened minor results.
And you're like count time pressure,
because it's two years program, right?
And obviously people are coming
from the diverse backgrounds and
they are exposed to new ideas constantly.
And that quite often leads
to the change of the course
quality throughout the two years training.
>> Great, so
we talk a lot about recruiting and career.
Now we can come back I think you after
mentioned about Frank or the OB professor.
Can you talk more about your
interaction with faculty,
like are there any personal stories?
>> Overall I would say that I'm quite
impressed by the level of faculty.
I'm not only taking classes in the GSB,
I am taking quite a lot of
classes across the street.
So I experience the computer
science department and
I've also taken some classes from
the Department of Economics.
And now I'm taking a class from
the Department of Symbolic Systems.
And I would say across Stanford overall,
it's been particular I'm quite
impressed with the faculty level.
>> Yeah, I agree, I think I'm taking
Touchy Feeley which is another really
famous course here at the GSB.
And my instructor Barry Dexter,
he is really helpful and
he not only takes care of the content
instructor of the course.
He understands and
reads everyone's journals and
would have one on one interactions.
I think the personal
attention from the faculty,
especially from him is something I really
tried out I think is really valuable here.
>> Yeah I just, I mean,
just quickly add some respects here.
I think one of the amazing things
about the GSB and what they do so
well is the balance between
faculty that are academics and
faculty that are industry leaders.
I think they do a great job of having,
whether it's teaching a class by
themselves or co-teaching a class.
Having industry leaders, you see,
the people I mean like Joe Peterson,
is a big one that comes to mind, they come
back and share their knowledge for us.
I think that's something that
Stanford's GSB does so well.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Yeah, so our next question will be,
what support and
the guidance do alumni provide?
I think you both touched it
when you were reaching out, or
even before Jesse met a lot of alumni.
So [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, I am happy to take this one
I think I leveraged the network
quite a lot before coming on campus.
So this was between me getting
the offer and me coming to campus.
I reached out to quite a few alums, I was
quite impressed with the response rate.
So quite a few of them were happy
to jump on the call, or meet for
a coffee to bounce some ideas.
And I think that helped me to
to understand what type of
experience to sign up for.
And also helped me to shape what I
want to do longer term at the GSB.
And just an anecdote on this one,
so a friend of mine,
he's reaching to quite a few
alums through cold emails.
And he told me that he was basically
tracking how many responses he got.
He said that he got about 70%
response rate on the cold emails,
which I think is quite impressive.
So a majority of people who were happy
to jump on the call with him, or
see him to meet for a coffee,
that [INAUDIBLE] never met the person.
>> Yeah, I did hear that as well,
I mean, pretty much, so
every email that I've sent to alumni,
I've received a response.
And just being willing to jump on a phone
call and have a chat about anything,
which has just been great.
>> Yeah, just another data point,
I'm with the Asian Business Student Club,
and we have a mentorship program.
So I got assigned two mentors,
and one of them is really,
really helpful in terms of helping me
land a job for my summer internship.
So actually, my summer plan is through
him, because he's an investor, and
he knows I'm passionate about media,
so he introduced me to the CEO.
Not only just cold emails,
there are structured programs,
like a mentorship program that
the [INAUDIBLE] just rolled out.
It will help you build a long lasting
relationship not just within the GSB
your relationships beyond.
>> Yeah, cool, so
our next question will be what global
experience have you had at GSB?
[CROSSTALK] all three of us went
to the India Global Study trip
together during the winter break.
We had a great experience there,
got to see India and there.
And then the people and the meetings
lined up was amazing, and I feel like I
got close with a lot of classmates,
including you two, so that was amazing.
>> Yeah exactly, so the trip itself,
I think that was definitely more my
best weeks in GSB so far,
it was quite an incredible trip.
This also brings us to the point I
mentioned earlier on the kind of tools
within GSB that kind of helps students
to integrate into the community.
I think that's a fascinating tool,
because for ten days,
you travel with your classmate.
And you really have a chance to get
to know them really, really well.
So I became really close
to those 30 people, yeah,
that was very fascinating,
the integration with the community.
>> Obviously I've got this coming up
this summer, so I haven't had it yet.
But it's something that I'm
really looking forward to,
a six-week trip to Europe
that the GSB helps pay for.
>> Where are you going?
>> So I'm going to be in Prague, and I'm
really looking forward to that experience,
obviously I've been in
India with you guys.
There's no shortage of trips
throughout the academic year that our
fellow classmates put together
that you can jump on.
[INAUDIBLE] with a group
over winter break,
[INAUDIBLE] a bunch of people
were traveling over spring break.
So definitely no shortage of
global experiences you can have.
>> Great, our next question would be,
what are the biggest challenges
you have faced in your first year?
>> I think I can start off, I think
coming from a non traditional background,
also as an international student.
I struggled to find my place here, because
I feel like everybody is so accomplished.
I feel, how can I get approved
by my peers and classmates?
I feel there is definitely
an impostor syndrome within me.
So how did I get here, so
it took me some time to settle in.
I felt overwhelming support
from all my classmates,
whether they were internationals or
American classmates.
And I feel, it just takes time,
so after the first quarter,
after I found some rhythm and
retooled my life, it got better and
better, now I feel like
I can be myself here.
>> In my experience,
I would say that for me, the whole GSB
experience to a large extent is a lesson
around the importance of focus.
And that was especially tough and
important during the first
couple of months at GSB.
It's still an issue, but there are so
many things happening in parallel.
You constantly need to prioritize,
there are so many questions to answer.
What classes you prioritize, what type
of community within GSB should be your
priority, how you approach
your career decision.
There's so
many questions you need to answer,
I think that was especially
difficult during the first quarter.
>> Yeah, I think that as well,
I think coming from England,
having not sat in a classroom for
a long time,
when I started [INAUDIBLE] drinking
from a phial, [INAUDIBLE].
And obviously with the court system here,
it is extremely dynamic.
Ten weeks classes over ten weeks, so for
me, it was really just getting
into the flow of things.
And like you guys have touched on,
some balancing on the impostor syndrome,
which I think everybody
has to some degree.
How much to [INAUDIBLE] all of the other
activities that are running in parallel.
And really coming to a realization
that you don't need to
do every single one of them.
So yeah, I think getting the balance
of the workload and your social life,
and also taking some time to just
chill out and sing to yourself.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So we're almost out of time today,
but before I go, Argon and Hofsky,
any final words of advice for
international students thinking
about applying to Stanford for
MBA, maybe a couple words?
>> Yeah, okay, sure, a couple words for
[INAUDIBLE], I would probably say that as
all of us mentioned, it's to
a large extent about the community.
And I would suggest to spend some
time studying the community.
Meet people from GSB who you can approach,
and just try to understand for
yourself whether these are the people
you want to be around for
the next two years of your life.
And if the answer is yes [INAUDIBLE]
it's a fascinating place to be.
>> Yeah, I think for me, it would just
be making sure that you have the best
possible application for
yourself prepared before you apply.
I think whether that's GMAT, whether
that's talking to current students,
reaching out around your essays and
how to shape them, doing research for
your essays.
I think just make sure that you're
really putting your best foot
forward before you apply.
>> Yeah, as for me, my advice would
be just be yourself, be authentic.
I think only you know what
you're truly passionate about.
Only you know what kind of story you
can tell, you are unique as a person.
So don't be afraid, be different,
having non-traditional
background is not a problem, international
student, also, be proud of yourself.
>> Okay, great, so now we'll wrap up,
thank you both for joining us, and
thank you for everyone in the audience for
participating.
You can learn more about
the MBA program and
the admission process on the GSB website.
The application for the next application
cycle will be available in June.
Thanks again and have a great day.